si vous aimez l'exploration et la
technologie je vous emmène pour une
découverte qui est absolument incroyable
Jean-Louis Étienne bonjour bonjour vous
êtes médecin explorateur et vous lancez
une nouvelle expédition qui s'appelle
polar pod parce que pour nous expliquer
ce qui est polar pod voilà pod c'est une
plateforme verticale c'est un navire
vertical qui fait 100 m de haut 75 m
sous l'eau il est très stable dans la
Grosse mère et on va explorer annonce de
tempête qu'on appelle les 50e hurlants
qui essaient océan qui fait le tour de
l'Antarctique qui est loin qui est
difficile d'accès et donc on va s'y
engager pendant trois ans pour faire un
inventaire de la faune il pourrait
explorer sa capacité à réguler le climat
pour cette expédition vous êtes
partenaire avec TCL comment c'est fait
cette rencontre avec avec TCL la
rencontre avec TCL c'est un partenariat
qui était à la fois technique n'importe
des téléviseurs du matériel à la fois
sur le polarpone et le navire
ravitailleur et puis un partenariat
financier aussi c'est un soutien moi je
serai à bord au moins au début parce que
ça fait longtemps que je travaille sur
ce projet là et je suis impatient de
voir comment ce navire vertical va se
comporter dans la grosse merde